[MUSIC PLAYING]
FERNANDA VIEGAS:
Thanks for coming.
My name is Fernanda Viegas.
I'm part of Google Brain.
I'm also a leader in the
PAIR initiative, which stands
for People + AI Research.
And I'm very excited
to be joined today
by this wonderful panel.
So here to my side is Rajen
Sheth, he's director of product
management at Google
Cloud AI, Daphne Luong,
engineering director at
Google, and John Platt,
director of applied
science in Google AI.
And today, we're going to
talk about opportunities,
challenges, and strategies
to develop AI for everyone.
So if you could, please, I
would love for each one of you
just to talk very briefly
about what do you do at Google.
RAJEN SHETH: My
name is Rajen Sheth
and I run the product
team for cloud AI.
And so what we're doing
is within Google Cloud,
we're trying to figure out how
can we bring the best of AI
to developers and
to enterprises.
And so how do we give developers
a great platform to build on?
But then how do we take some
of the best of Google's AI
and make it so that they're
available as services
for developers?
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Thank you.
DAPHNE LUONG: My
name is Daphne Luong.
I work in Google AI,
human computation, data,
and natural language
understanding.
JOHN PLATT: I'm John Platt.
And I help run the
applied science org
inside of Google AI.
We're super excited by
all the opportunities
in science related to things
like biology or physics.
And we believe that computer
science, especially machine
learning and AI, can really
help accelerate that.
So that's what my org does.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Thank you.
So one of the
things that is very
inspiring to me about this panel
and about a lot of the themes
going on at I/O this
year is AI for everyone.
And so I know that in PAIR,
one of the main research
themes we have is how do
you design human-centered AI
technology?
How do you start
with a user in mind
and then design machine learning
technology that fits with that?
So one of the things I'd
love to ask each one of you
to talk about a little bit is
what does "AI for everyone"
mean to you?
RAJEN SHETH: So for
me, it means, really,
how do you make
AI easy and useful
for people that want to use it?
And I think there are two
big problems that we're
seeing right now with AI.
One is that there isn't as
much skill out there or as much
knowledge about how to
build AI models, especially
deep learning, as
there should be.
And so we're trying to
both build tools for that
and to make it so that
more people can access AI,
but then can also learn about AI
and figure out how to use that.
What we're finding,
for example, is
that there are probably
in the tens of thousands
of people out there that know
how to use deep learning,
probably in the order
of a couple of million
of data scientists out there.
But there are 21
million developers.
And so our goal is
how do we get AI
to be accessible by the
21 million developers?
And the second part
of that is usefulness.
How do we actually make
it so that AI is useful?
How do we go-- especially
for businesses,
beyond where they can
not only do cool things,
but they can do things
that are useful,
that actually are vital
to their business?
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Definitely.
DAPHNE LUONG: To me, getting
everyone involved and aware
so that algorithms
have representation
for all of our users.
So on the data side,
this means that we
need to have data
that's representative
of all our users.
JOHN PLATT: Yeah.
Well, for me, AI for
everyone is trying
to get the benefits of AI
to a large part of society
or across the world.
So what we do is we look
for leverage points.
We're not trying to get
everyone in the world to use AI.
We're trying to have the
fruits of what AI can provide.
So if we can find these
leverage points, where
a local application of AI can
really help the whole world,
that's what we're looking for.
That's why I'm super
excited about applying
AI and machine learning
to problems in science,
because science can lead to
breakthrough technologies.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Great.
I think one of the
interesting things here
for this panel and this
theme is that each one of you
is coming from a very
different perspective.
So Rajen, I think about you
as coming from the product
slash business side of things.
Daphne, you're helping build
some of the fundamental blocks,
like the data, the
fundamental data creation
blocks for being able to
do this technology at all.
And then John, you're coming
from a research perspective.
How do we enable the scientists?
How do we enable
science at large?
So one of the things that comes
up whenever we talk about AI,
whenever we talk about
machine learning,
is this notion of
representation.
And I want to start at
the beginning with that.
I want to talk about data.
And so Daphne, I
was really excited
when I heard that you were
going to be part of this panel
because I think about you
as the data czar of Google.
[LAUGHS]
And so your work is a lot
about creating better ways
to scale up.
For instance, how
do we gather data?
How do we do it in
an insightful way?
And so one of the
things I'd love
for you to talk
about a little bit
is the representation
of data sets at Google.
What does that look like today?
DAPHNE LUONG: Yeah.
So having semantically
meaningful and systematic--
correctly calibrated,
labeled data,
and scale is really crucial
for machine learning.
And from a representation
perspective, some of the data
sets out there are
not well balanced.
For example, if you
look at Wikipedia data,
"he," the pronoun "he"
is mentioned so much more
than "she."
So inside Google, we
have a lot of data.
And an example set that
I want to talk about
is the audio data set that
we open sourced last year.
The data sets had 2.1 million
video with 8.5k hour of audio.
But then we annotate it with
around 500 classes of sound.
That's pretty
interesting, right?
You have sounds from speech
and music, all the way
to engine sounds or
burping or gargling.
So then from that
perspective, it's
really important to
have audio and sounds
from all over the world,
like having sounds from kids.
From India is very different
from China and the US.
So that kind of
thing is what I think
we should think about
whenever we make data sets.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: So
that's wonderful.
Yeah, when I became aware of all
the different open source data
sets that we have put
out, it's really exciting
to see audio, video, text.
You have translation.
You have all of those.
But whenever you're talking
about data in machine learning,
you're also talking
about challenges.
So one of the things you started
touching on a little bit--
and I want to pull
that out more--
is this notion of
representation,
making sure that the data
set has good representation
from different users,
different communities.
And that's a hard thing to do.
So I'm curious, what are we
at Google doing about that?
How are you thinking about that?
Yeah.
So Google users in
communities, they
have been very generous,
donating data and stuff for us
to make our product better.
An example is Google Guide.
How many have used that
Google Guide in the audience?
So, yes.
So on the data
front, we are also
doing something really similar.
We have a Crowdsource app,
which is an app and on the web.
Right now, since
the last two years,
we actually had
two million users
donating to the app
from all over the world,
actually 233 countries.
That's a lot of
different people.
And we had 200 million
donations from people answering
questions, all
the way from, hey,
can you see this sign from the
street in an Indonesian city,
versus, hey, how do
you use this sentence?
What's the sentiment of
the sentence in Hindi?
So there's all those data.
And those data actually help
us make products better--
help people navigate streets
where there is no sign,
from like a landmark navigation,
making the keyboard more
accessible, as well as making
heavy [INAUDIBLE] detail
labeled data set.
So I think that's
really important.
If you don't have
the Crowdsource app,
please download it.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Great.
Thank you.
One of the things about
audio that I had never
thought about until I
read this is that there
is a huge discrepancy
between even voices of adults
versus children.
So you have to think about
many, many different dimensions
of diversity.
DAPHNE LUONG: Yeah.
And then from the
app, we actually
have user-initiated groups
that's in 35 countries.
We're actually really excited
about the whole contributions.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Awesome.
OK.
So now, moving on a little
bit about from data.
Whenever we talk about AI for
everyone, one of the, I think,
first questions
that comes to mind
is how do we make AI accessible
and better for our users?
And Rajen, here I'm
going to turn to you.
And since you are helping
lead these services on cloud,
how do you think about
designing these ML tools
so that they are easy
for users to use?
And then a segue
question there too,
if you could talk a little bit
about what are the difficulties
that you're starting to see.
What are the patterns
where users get stuck?
RAJEN SHETH: Yeah, yeah.
Great question.
I think there are two
big parts of that.
One is how do we make it easy
for people to create models?
But then the second part
is how do we make sure
that those models are fair, are
not biased, are really serving
the purpose in the right way?
Because it is very
easy for people
to just take what they've been
doing manually and end up,
encoding bias into a model.
So on one part of it,
what we're doing is
we're providing a
variety of tools.
One of the most interesting
things that we're working on
is Cloud AutoML.
And so Cloud AutoML is a
way by which you can give us
a data set, and then
we'll use machine
learning to create a machine
learning model for that data
set.
The first area we're
doing this with
is image recognition,
where you can give us
a set of images that are
labeled and then we'll
give you a highly
accurate model on top
of that to predict for images.
And so that has really
helped this expand.
We have 15,000 people that have
signed up for access to that.
And we're seeing amazing
use cases, everything
from really large companies
to very small companies who
are doing things
around, for example,
helping farmers manage their
field or helping track litter
and making sure to track
litter back to the producers.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: How
much technical expertise
do I, as a user, need to
have if I want to use AutoML?
RAJEN SHETH: Yeah,
great question.
We're trying to
orient it to make it
so that you need to
have limited or no ML
expertise to be able to use it.
And if you look at our UI,
it's very similar to, say,
Google Photos.
You upload your pictures.
You label them.
We actually are integrating with
a lot of the services Daphne
and team are using to have
us label it if you want that.
And then you just hit
train, and then we'll
create a model for you.
However, that said,
getting the right data
set is the key part there.
So even if you don't have
to go create the model,
you have to create
the right data set.
And so there, we're trying
to provide tools to make sure
that people are able to
create the right data set
and figure out where there
are flaws in the data set.
And then on the other side of
this, around things like bias,
we're trying to figure
out tools around that
and also help advise
customers with best practices
to make sure that the data
set they're putting in
can actually produce
the right results.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: OK.
And so data continues to be one
of those bottlenecks, right?
RAJEN SHETH: It is the
foundation of this.
And you put in the
wrong data, you end up
with the wrong results.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Yeah.
OK.
John, of the themes, as
you all have been seeing,
is diversity--
diversity in data sets.
Also, how do you create
these experiences
for users, who are not
themselves machine learning
experts, to be able to
use this technology?
I'm also curious to hear
from you about diversity
and representation on the side
of machine learning, developers
and researchers.
The reason I'm looking
at you is because you're
working with scientists.
And so these are people who are
going to be potentially needing
custom models.
They are going to be pushing
the envelope sometimes.
But they may not themselves
be machine learning experts.
So I'm curious about
your thoughts there.
JOHN PLATT: Well,
science is getting
to be increasingly data driven.
A lot of scientists
like physicists,
geologists to biologists,
they do their job
by gathering large
amounts of data.
So they're already kind of
getting into data science.
And so there's a big
opportunity right now
for them to use machine learning
to make themselves be much more
productive.
The way I look at
it is it's kind
of like giving a
scientist thousands
of undergraduate
assistants, in other words,
something to look at, slides--
if you could examine
slides of cells,
you could just have thousands of
assistants look at it for you.
That's sort of one example.
So I don't know if this
answers your question,
but I'm really
excited that we can
build models to help scientists
do specific things to help
accelerate their research.
And we actually
collaborate with scientists
to help build these
kind of models.
So I hope that
answered your question.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: And
what kinds of scientists
are you working with?
JOHN PLATT: Well, the
applied science people,
there's a bunch of us working
with biomedical research trying
to understand the core
research of disease
like neurodegenerative diseases.
There's a bunch of us working
on climate and energy.
So we're working with a company
called TAE Technologies, trying
to figure out whether we
can make fusion energy,
make it commercially relevant.
So we span across biology,
physics, chemistry.
We work with a bunch of people
who simulate quantum chemistry.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: And I
guess the same question
I asked Rajen, I'd
like to ask you,
which is, what do you
see as the biggest
difficulties for scientists
to do this kind of work today?
Are there patterns?
Is it data?
Is it understanding how
to put together models?
What do you see?
JOHN PLATT: Well,
they generally don't
want to build models themselves,
although some of them do.
There is an increasing crossover
between scientists and computer
scientists.
But I think they would prefer
to have a productivity tool.
In other words, can we help
them build a productivity tool
for their own research?
And either they could try
to build it themselves
if they know machine
learning or we can help them.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: OK.
So along those lines,
one of the things
that I've been
very excited about
is a few months
ago, folks in PAIR,
in collaboration with others at
Google, launched TensorFlow.js.
And this is really significant,
in the sense that--
what we were talking
about, in terms
of democratizing the
technology and bringing
machine learning to the web.
TensorFlow.js speaks the
native language of the web,
speaks JavaScript.
And so now, you
have a whole new set
of developers who
can start to take
advantage of this technology.
And we are already
starting to see
some interesting applications.
For instance, one
developer who decided
to train a model based on his
web camera to make the mouse
move in different directions
just by where he was looking.
So if he looked up,
the mouse would go up.
If he looked down, the
mouse would go down.
And the reason he did that
was because he was trying
to help a friend who
had suffered a stroke
and became paraplegic.
So that to me,
again, starts to talk
about this possibility
of bringing
this technology into your
personal-- what do you need?
How can you train these models
for your specific purposes?
As we talk about
democratizing the technology,
as we talk about
bringing it to everybody,
one of the things that
I think we at Google
are very mindful of is that we
have to do that with insight
and responsibility.
You want to be thinking ahead.
So one question
I have, Rajen, is
since you are providing
this service, what
happens if you have bad actors
trying to use your service?
And what safeguards
could you provide?
RAJEN SHETH: Yeah.
That's a great
question, something
that is very much
top of mind for us.
Because as we see
more people use AI,
we want to make sure that we're
providing those safeguards,
whether it's safeguards
or best practices
to make sure that it's
used in the right way.
On one hand, when you have
things like open source
technologies, it's very
hard to prevent people
from doing bad things if
they want to do bad things.
But one advantage we have
with cloud is that we can.
We can put in terms of services
or acceptable use policies,
things like that
to make sure people
are using this in the right way.
And I think one thing
we're discovering with AI
is that we have to rethink that.
It's not an infrastructure
technology anymore.
We have to rethink the uses.
And that's something that
we're doing quite a bit.
Another thing that
worries me too
is beyond just
bad actors, people
unintentionally doing
things that might be bad
and not even knowing
that they are.
And it goes back to
some of the things
we talked about with
bias and fairness.
In a lot of cases,
people aren't intending
to create something
that's biased,
but they end up
creating something
that's biased because of
the data that's coming in.
And so that's another
area that we're
looking at quite a bit, which
is how do we help people out
there, our customers,
developers, have
the tools to be able to do
this well such that they're
not unintentionally
creating bad models too?
DAPHNE LUONG:
Alongside of tooling,
I think it's also important
to get people trained all
the way from the
beginning, end to end,
really mindful of
the data, diversity,
what you need for data.
We actually train,
even annotator,
so they're aware, having
diversity along the whole path.
So I think that's
important, and then
for other practitioners
to understand
about best data, best
practices for machine learning.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Absolutely.
JOHN PLATT: I mean,
I usually think
about this from the
research perspective
because I'm a researcher.
And we write and publish papers.
And we have to
think very carefully
about when we write a paper.
I mean, the intent is to have
a positive impact on the world.
So before we release
the paper, we say,
is this going to have a positive
impact in the world or not?
Now, you can't always predict.
There's going to be
unintended consequences
of releasing a technology.
But we try to do
the best we can.
And we generally have a
bias towards openness,
because it's just
generally, the priority
is that it's better to
share these technologies.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Yeah.
I have to say as a
researcher myself,
I love the ethos of just
publishing and open sourcing.
And I have never been
in a field like this
before where the whole
idea is you publish
as soon as you have a finding.
And then you submit
to a conference.
I had never seen that before.
And I think it's
wonderful because it
means that the field
progresses much faster.
I want to come back to one point
that we were talking about,
which is this notion
of there might
be unintended consequences.
Or even with the
best of intentions,
you may not know that
your data is biased
or that there might be
a skew or something.
And there, one thought I'd love
to put out is this notion that
building tools so that
people can inspect the data,
and also opening up
the community of people
who inspect these things.
So in PAIR, for instance, one
of the things we've been doing
is building tools,
visualization tools,
that visualize your
entire data set and allows
you to very easily see
things like, oh, this
is the shape of my data.
This is the distribution.
This is what female data
points look like or male data
points or children data points.
And what this means
is that because it's
this user interface where the
experiences, the visualization,
it means not only
developers can look at this.
It means that product managers
can look at this, executives,
whoever--
different stakeholders can
start having a conversation,
sit together and be
like, oh, I don't know.
I saw something strange
in the data set.
Or what do you think is
going to happen when we
facet by this dimension here?
And so I'd love to hear a
little bit of your thoughts
on the importance of broadening
the conversation around doing
AI for everyone so that
it's not a conversation that
is happening only
amongst developers.
Obviously, the developers
are super important.
But I also think it's
a conversation that
needs to happen with a
broader set of stakeholders.
RAJEN SHETH: I guess
one thought on that--
and it's interesting you--
in the previous
conversation, you're
talking about how
rapidly this is going.
One way I usually start out
my presentations to customers
is the first slide, I show a
picture of the Mosaic browser
from 1994.
And my point with it
is that all of us, we
remember back to what that was.
And before that
point, the internet
had been around for a very
long time before that point.
But that was when
the internet started
to go out to many more
people for many more things.
You started to see everything
from checking sports scores all
the way to e-commerce,
all kinds of things.
And it opened up many
more possibilities
and opened up a
lot more questions.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Yes.
RAJEN SHETH: And
also questions where
there needed to be more tools,
tools to make it easier,
but tools to make people safe.
And I think we are at 1994.
We are at that point
for AI right now.
It's been used for years
and years and years,
but now, it's being used
and many, many more ways.
And so I think we need to think
about tooling in that way.
New problems are starting
to come up every single day.
And new technologies are
coming out every single day.
And so we're going to need
to think about that not just
as a developer
community, but then
in coordination with how it's
being used and the people
that it's affecting.
JOHN PLATT: Rajen
and I were just
talking about the
first spam detector
before we came up in 1997.
I remember the first spam email
that got sent in the '80s.
And so as new
problems come up, you
need to have certain new tools
to help fight the problem.
RAJEN SHETH: That's a good
point, that for a long time
you didn't need a spam detector.
And then all of a
sudden, you did.
And then you had to have tools
to be able to work with it.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Another
thing, another aspect
of this of broadening
the conversation,
especially when we're
talking about products also,
is this notion of
having in the same room
your technical team, your
design team, for instance,
and your PMs and so forth.
And so one of the things
we're doing at Google
is finding ways of involving
the designers, the UXers
from the beginning and
educating them around machine
learning as a design material.
How do you think about
that as, literally,
a material you're
going to design with?
And if you think about it, it's
a very challenging material
because it's something that
each person in a product
might have a slightly
different user experience.
My experience might be
very different from yours.
Certain things may be
automated in different ways
for different people
at different times.
And so it makes that UX,
the user interaction,
much more challenging.
That space becomes a lot bigger.
And so again, when we are
talking about AI for everyone,
it really means
this conversation
that needs to happen
between multiple parties.
One thing I have to come
back to before we run out
of time, John, is this
notion of science.
One of the things that I think
there's a lot of excitement
around is that
machine learning could
be a new paradigm
for scientists,
that finally we could
solve certain, very
complex scientific problems
using these new tools.
So I'm curious about your
thoughts as why is it
that AI makes such a difference
in these very complex spaces?
JOHN PLATT: Well, that's
an excellent question.
Right now, the current state
of AI and machine learning
is still very perceptual.
We're very, very good at looking
at images, listening to sounds.
And so you can imagine,
as I said before,
I like to talk about these
thousands of undergraduates.
They would be listening
or looking at the data.
And so that's a great
productivity term for science.
In the long run--
people are starting to
research into this--
but in the long
run, what we really
want is something
called causal models,
where the machine learning or
AI algorithm actually tries
to understand what caused what.
I mean, that's still very,
very early in research.
But that's almost the
essence of science,
a scientific model
explains this caused that.
And you can extrapolate if you
know what the causal model is.
So I think that's sort of
the long-term trend for AI.
But we're not there yet
because our models don't really
understand causation yet.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: So one of
the things along those lines,
we had a visiting scientist
in our group in Cambridge.
He's in earthquake science.
You know who I'm talking about.
He's a professor
at Harvard who came
and spent half a year with us.
And one of the things I
thought was incredibly
inspiring about what he
was doing-- so obviously,
as an earthquake scientist, you
want to predict earthquakes.
It's incredibly hard.
We can't do it well yet.
But the thing that
he was able to do--
so I did not know anything
about earthquake science--
he explained to me that
this is the kind of science
that lives in HPC, high
performance computing.
So huge, huge computers
that will spend entire weeks
doing very, very gnarly
computation, trying to
simulate where
might an aftershock
happen after an
earthquake, things
that Californians should
care a lot about--
and I'm sure you do.
So imagine something
that takes a week running
on huge computers.
He was able to get these
kinds of simulation results
that were just as good
using a simple neural net.
It was so simple, the
neural net was so simple
that it was the
kind of neural net
where you could
count the neurons.
That's how simple it was.
And so one, he was stunned
and incredibly happy
because it meant he didn't
need to wait a whole week
and using a ton of compute
power to do the same kind
of simulations he was doing.
So that in itself was a win.
But then the deeper question,
and one of the things
that gives me a
lot of excitement,
is what exactly was this
neural net figuring out
about the physics of the Earth
that we haven't figured out
yet?
And again, if we could interpret
what this system was doing,
what this neural net was doing,
if we could learn from it,
could we become better
scientists ourselves?
And you're starting to
see this in science.
You're starting to
see this in medicine.
So for instance, the brain that
work with diabetic retinopathy,
where these systems are looking
at the image of the back
of your eye, your fundus.
And not only are they being able
to understand whether or not
you have the
diabetic retinopathy,
but they're also being
able to do things
like understand the
gender of the patients
and the cardiovascular
disease risk, things
that doctors themselves
couldn't necessarily
see in these images.
So again, part of
the race now is
to understand what are
these systems learning
that we couldn't learn?
So can we become better
doctors, better scientists
by using this?
Can we learn back?
Can we listen back
from these machines?
So we have a few minutes to go.
But I have two more questions.
One is for you, Rajen.
What are you seeing
of the ability of AI
to really help businesses?
I guess I'm curious
about what have
been some of the most
successful cases,
but also some of
the most surprising?
And you're like, whoa, I didn't
know we could do AI for this.
RAJEN SHETH: Yeah, yeah.
There are a bunch of
things that we've seen.
There are definitely
certain industries
that are farther ahead.
Tech industry, of course,
there's a lot being used there.
Financial services, there's
a lot already being used.
But then there are many
emerging use cases, which
I think are pretty amazing.
Some of the examples we see,
like on the manufacturing line.
Can you use vision to figure
out if a part is OK or not,
like if a tire coming
down the factory line
is going to be a good
tire or it might actually
bear risk to the person.
Those kinds of things are things
that we're starting to see.
Retail is another case.
How do you actually
make it so that you
can make the experience
of the user better?
So I'll give you an example.
We're using AutoML with Disney.
My son happens to be a
massive Lightning McQueen
fan, from "Cars."
And I'm sure many of you have
kids or family members that
are big Disney fans.
He has an insatiable
appetite for Disney stuff,
and stuff with
Lightning McQueen.
Now, with the technology
that we've developed,
you can search on
shopDisney for everything
with Lightning McQueen on
it, whether or not it says it
in the description or not.
It'll do it by
visual inspection.
Those kinds of things
are really interesting,
interesting use cases.
And so we're
starting to see that.
One of the things I
think that is important,
though, is that we need to
get businesses to the point
where they're not
thinking about,
hey, I'm using AI to
do this, but where
the users are feeling magic.
And it doesn't matter if it's
AI behind the covers or not.
And that's where I think
things like what we've
done with Google
Photos and stuff
like that is really incredible
because it's not about AI,
it's about the user experience.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: That's awesome.
So we talked about
some of the challenges,
some of the strategies.
I want to end on
the opportunities.
We talked about some of
the opportunities also,
but I want to end on that
note, on the opportunities.
In the last year,
we've seen AI being
applied to various domains
in really interesting ways.
So you have medicine, science.
You have farming.
We were talking about
some of those examples.
And I'd love to hear from each
one of you what opportunity
are you excited about for
the next however many years?
John, do you want to start?
JOHN PLATT: OK.
Well, you mentioned
biomedical research,
so now I can't talk about that.
So let me talk about another
project I find really exciting,
which I mentioned before,
which is we're actually
working to see if we can
get fusion energy to be
a real commercial
source of energy
in order to displace
fossil fuels.
Because right now, the
world is burning way too
many fossil fuels and
flooding the atmosphere
with carbon dioxide.
So we're actually using
machine learning to help
this company, TAE Technologies.
And we're helping in two ways.
We're trying to optimize
their experiments.
We're actually helping
them design experiments
through optimization.
And we're using Bayesian
methods to actually help
them debug the plasma
inside their machine.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Oh wow.
JOHN PLATT: So the
goal is going to be
trying to make this
plasma about as
hot as the center of the sun.
And if we can do that, we can
measure its heat loss rate
and see if we can actually
get to a commercially
relevant fusion, which
would really, I think,
revolutionize the world.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: When
can we expect that?
JOHN PLATT: Well, I don't
want to promise anything.
We'll have some good scientific
results, I think, in 2019.
We won't have what they
call breakeven fusion then,
but we'll have some very solid
results predicting the heat
loss rate.
So we'll know a lot
more in about a year.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Awesome.
DAPHNE LUONG: For me, I'm
very excited about two things.
The first thing is
really we'll continue
to work with the Crowdsource
contributors who built really
diverse, globally
diverse data set,
that not a single company
couldn't build by itself,
but actually leveraging
everyone who's
passionate about representing
their part of the world
to create data set
that we can open source
to use by everyone-- and then
similarly for machine learning.
Since I do a lot of
volunteering outside of work
with social entrepreneurs
across the world,
I really want to see that
ML available for nonprofits
to do sort of air quality models
or maybe [INAUDIBLE] books
they do, using Translate to make
books available for thousands
of different languages
and for mother tongue.
So I think that's exciting.
I'm looking forward to that.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Nice.
RAJEN SHETH: I
think for me, there
are two things I'm
passionate about.
One is health care and
the other is education.
And so health care,
just this idea
like you talked about,
being able to use AI
to do early disease detection.
You have this incredible
impact on one human being
and on many human beings, that
and on families around them
and things like that.
And that, I think,
could be really amazing.
Education, I spend
most of my time
here at Google working on
our education products.
And the idea of imagining an
environment where every student
can learn in the way
that they want to learn--
at their own pace,
in their own style--
and having AI help power
that can be transformative.
You can harness the potential
of every single individual
in a way that was
never possible before.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: I'm
going to segue from that
and say, again, one of the
things that has been really
inspiring to see with
things like TensorFlow.js
is that we have now professors
at a number of universities
who are building educational
materials around this.
And I feel like that's
really important.
I'm really excited about this
because it not only lowers
the barrier for entry
in this technology,
but it also, I think, starts
to hit a much more diverse set
of developers who are
interested in using
this technology for
different things
that we haven't
even dreamt of yet.
So I'm very excited about that.
The other thing that I
think is really good to see
is how the conversation
around machine learning
has started to touch on things
like ethics and fairness.
And I think that's
really important.
I'm really happy that here at
Google, we think very deeply
about these questions.
And both from a
research perspective,
what are research
things we can do to help
address some of these problems?
But also policy, product-wise,
design-wise, it's
a broader conversation.
So with that, I am going
to thank our panel.
Thank you so much.
It's been so inspiring to
hear not only your insights,
but to have you share
your experience,
as I said, from many different
parts of Google on this topic
today with us.
Thank you.
JOHN PLATT: Thank you.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]